Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I'm
your host, Rawkode, sometimes known as David Flanagan.
Today, we are continuing our exploration of the
cloud native landscape and taking a look at
a project that wants to make building microservices
easier.
That project is Dapr.
And to guide us through today's journey, I
am joined by my friend, Salaboy Mauricio.
Hey, man. How's it going?
Hey, David. How are you doing? Thank you
very much for the invite. You know, I
I Yeah. Didn't wanted to do something like
this for for a long time, and finally,
it's happening 2023.
And
that's that's I'm super happy. Thank you for
having me. We're squeezing the end right before
the end of the year, which is fantastic.
And it's nice to be able to set
and do this thing with an actual friendly
face. So, you know, thank you for taking
the time to to join me today.
Let's do it. Alright. So for anyone who's
not familiar with you, which I think is
impossible in our space Yeah. Could you please
tell us, you know, what you've been up
to, what you're doing now, and anything else
that you think is interesting?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. So I've been working
with Dapr for a company for a new
company that's called for a year now. Like,
my my anniversary was, like, a couple of
days ago. And I've been getting into the
Dapr community for the last year because I
found Dapr
like, as one of the missing pieces of,
you know, building applications on top of of
Kubernetes.
I've been working with Kubernetes for, like, seven
years now, always from that, like, developer perspective.
Right? Like, just trying to help developers to
get their applications up and running, but also
connected to each other and, like, implementing best
practices and finding the right tools to do
the right things.
And I found Dapr kinda like a the
Dapr project to be significant
in that space. Right? Like, it's very close
to developers. It's about APIs to build, you
know, better cloud native applications.
And, yeah, I've been trying to contribute to
the project, trying to integrate the project with
other projects and other communities in the CNCF
landscape and outside CNCF as well.
In the in the journey, in that journey,
basically, I've been meeting a lot of very
interesting folks and learning a lot of interesting
lessons. So, you know, whatever I can share
about that, it's it's always good.
Awesome. Amazing.
And you didn't mention your book. Do you
wanna talk about that as well?
I can talk about my book as well.
It's it's a funny thing, Riley, when you
when you write a book. I've started writing
my book, like, two years ago, and now
it's titled platform engineering on Kubernetes,
where I basically cover a bunch of open
source projects,
and how do they relate and how do
they work together to just build platforms on
top of Kubernetes, basically.
But, because I've been writing it for the
last two years, the moment that it got
printed, I had this feeling of, I don't
want to talk about this anymore.
But now is the time where I should
be talking a lot about it, right, because
it's out actually out. So yeah. So, you
know, the book is all about open source
tools for Kubernetes,
tools for teams and application delivery teams and
for operation people to build platforms that basically
help teams to just get software
running on top of Kubernetes,
going from pipelines,
from packaging,
from, application development tools like Dapr,
but also k native for running and auto
scaling,
a bunch of other things that people might
find interesting.
Yeah. I mean, that's the thing with Kubernetes.
Right? A lot of the tutorials out there
get you to the point where you can
keep control, apply an engine x deployment, and
then that's it. But there is so much
more that comes afterwards.
And it's good that we have resources now
that are starting to fill in the gaps
and and actually educate people on what they
need to know and to get them on
the right path.
One of the interesting things about the book,
and I guess that the main reason why
I decided to write it in the first
place, was that when you look into the
CNCF landscape, right, like, are tons of projects
built on top of the of the Kubernetes
APIs. Right? But they are all built and
designed in different ways for different purposes. So
getting them to work together sometimes and at
least two years ago wasn't that easy as
it it is today. So for me, it
was kinda like this whole exercise of making
sure that I can create an example
that can actually highlight,
you know, 20 different projects
and then see how each project is bringing
something to the table and also understanding the
gaps that, you know, when you combine two
or three projects together, kinda start popping up,
and you will need to sort out yourself.
Sweet. Awesome.
Alright. Let's move on to the topic at
hand then, Dapr. Can you give us the
thirty to sixty second pitch? What is Dapr
and why should people stay tuned?
Yeah. So Dapr is a CNCF project. It
was donated that's a very good question. When
exactly? I don't remember the date. But but
it's a it's a pretty mature project. Like,
it has it was created by Microsoft in
2019.
And,
basically, the main purpose of the project is
to allow people to
have kinda like a, like, an application level
API
that enable teams to interact with infrastructure without
knowing where that infrastructure is or what that
infrastructure is. The idea here is to provide
developers APIs that they can use and enable
platform teams to configure how these APIs are
implemented in different environments,
but at the same time providing kinda like
a like a seamless experience
across environments. Right? So you can have different
environments configured with different infrastructure in different completely
different ways, in completely different cloud providers,
but the application development experience is the same
because the APIs remain stable.
In order to in order to get that
working Kubernetes, there are tons of things that
needs to happen, and there are tons of
components and building blocks that the Dapr project
provides. And I guess that we can explore
with that side as well. Yeah. I mean,
just that paragraph that you gave us there.
I mean, that's no easy mission. Right? Trying
to be able to build applications in this
way, make them as portable as, you know,
what we have all really like from our
from our stack. But as you said, we're
going to explore Dapr hands on and see
where all the components are, how they work
together. And what I'm really excited about is
just can we show people a better developer
experience for bells in these type missions, which
are very tricky. Right? So
Yeah. You need to you need to add
on top of that that because we are
focused on APIs, the the entire experience is
is polyglot in a way.
The the idea that, like, there is no
language dependency
coming into into the the space. Right? Like,
the idea is that from any technology stack
that you're using, you should be able to
consume these APIs,
like, by just using, like, normal, you know,
language tools.
And and I feel that's pretty important, and,
also, it makes the mission a little bit
more complicated because now you are dealing with
tons of different technologies that do things in
slightly different ways, and they come with different
developer experiences and different ex you know, developer
workflows as well that you need to accommodate.
Alright. Awesome.
Okay. I'm gonna share my screen and we're
gonna get started with the hands on component.
And before I do that, I'll just say
hi to two familiar faces. John Luca and
Marino, saying hi in the chat. Hey. Nice
to see you. Hey, folks.
Alright. Let's see. I have the correct screen
shared which is always a good start.
Here we have the Dapr website.
You can find that at dapr.io.
We're gonna dive straight into the documentation.
And I'm assuming we'll install,
you know, Dapr itself.
I haven't done anything in advance. Everything that
you see here is everything that you will
need to do to be able to replicate
this at home or work forever.
So I'll click on get started. We're gonna
grab the CLI.
We'll do Yeah.
So let me let me try to explain
a little bit, like, the getting a starter
experience. Right? Like, you can download the CLI.
The CLI will
basically help you with some developer workflows initially
just to set up different environments and different
the tools in different ways depending on what
you are trying to achieve.
In general, for developing applications,
again, I don't think that having the CLI
is a requirement, but just go go go
ahead, please. And if you can install it,
like, we can go through the getting started
guys.
Alright.
I just assumed that we needed it, but
it's good to know that we don't. Oh,
I'm late. I'm on late mode. Let me
I don't wanna blind everyone at home. So
I kinda I kinda love the, like, the,
like, the CLI experience in general.
But when I think about, like, going to
different developers using different technologies, like, Node. Js
or Java or or Rust, right, like, completely
different text stacks,
I I always think that adding a new
CLI
will introduce something that that developer will need
to learn. Right? Each CLI will come with
kinda like a different workflow, a different set
of steps that you need to execute to
achieve something specifically,
and that, again, will push the developer to
stop doing what they are doing and start
learning that specific CLI and all the arguments
and all the parameters.
So I tend to go without the CLI,
but you will see that in the in
the getting started guides, most of the exercises
of will
use that CLI to bootstrap Dapr itself.
Nice.
We're in a wonderful position where I decided
to try out new shell, and I don't
have any of my paths configured properly whatsoever.
Nice.
But I think we can
do. Would that work? Let's see.
I think so.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well, I've got oh, no. It didn't work.
Oh, I appended it, but it didn't save
it. Alright. Okay. So e n v dot
path equals.
Alright.
Now I've blown away everything else. That's that's
yeah. That's not the the best. But you
have it there. Alright? Like, you printed it
before. So Alright. Today is not the day
for me to be experimenting with new shells.
CSA cheese?
What is it? Homebrew? It's not.
I have no idea what homebrew is. Let
me check. I can check my No. It's
okay. Let me You will find it. Of
homebrew. Ben, yeah. Okay. So we wanna There
you go.
Brew. Better. Dapr.
Better, cool.
There you go. And one of the things
I did is he's completely irrelevant. Right? Because
I was trying to convince myself to switch
to a new shell. I had to remove
the path of least resistance, which is when
it frustrates me just jump back to said
shell. I knew all of my said shell
configuration. So it's super vanilla.
But we're not gonna. Alright.
So we have to see a live. We
didn't particularly need it, but that's alright. And
I'm gonna go back to the documentation where
we're going to click on quick start, and
we're gonna work through one of these today.
And then I think you're going to show
us a couple of extra things on top
of that afterwards. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I think I think that we can
do that. And it's kinda like important to
see that what you will see there in
the quick starts basically are, you know, the
Dapr building blocks, something that the Dapr project
called building blocks. And each of these building
blocks is basically exposing a different set of
APIs to do different things. You can see
the first one that it's listed there, it's
called publish and subscribe. Right? That will give
you APIs to emit events and consume events.
Then you have the service invocation API as
well that will allow allow you to do
more resilient service to service communications and service
discovery as well.
And the management APIs will give you, like,
a key value store API to store keys
and values, just going through an API and
not connecting to a database or or, like,
a Redis or something like that.
And then there are a bunch of others,
and I would like to say that workflows
is the one that gets me, really, really
excited. It's it's something that it has been
released, like, pretty off like, pretty recently, and
it's getting better and better. So I'm really
keen to see how how that evolves in
the future.
But I think that for for
this and to demonstrate what kinda like what
Dapr is about, I think that we can
take a look at the state management APIs.
That's probably the the simplest to get.
Yeah. I mean, workflows is definitely interesting. Right?
I'm seeing long running Yeah. Powerful and stateful
applications. This is this always puts me back
to people trying to make temporal easier, which
is such a noble mission. We need to
make durable execution
easier for people to host and operate themselves.
But I love workflows, but you're right. Let's
let's keep it chill today and come back
to that. So so
so this is the thing. Right? Like, because
these are, like, components.
What's happening with the Dapr project is that
you will see that we have a lot
of different component APIs,
and then something like the workflow API and
the workflow functionality basically builds on top of
all the components.
Right? Like, we are starting to construct more
higher level components that are built and relying
on lower level things.
Alright. Let's
start off with state management. I always say
on this show or in fact, in life
conferences anywhere that I am. Right? If your
application doesn't have state, you're not making any
money. So let's cover state management.
And I guess that that that's a very
good point. Right? Like, if you think about
applications,
80% of the applications will be doing kinda,
like, reading data and storing data somewhere else.
Right? Like, they are processing data and then
just need to store it somewhere. And I
think that this is what, the state management
API is all about. You can see there
in the in the example in the graph.
Right? You see that you have your application,
in this case, like an order processor, and
then you have Dapr in the middle, which
is the one providing the APIs. And then
you have a backing implementation in this case.
Redis is an example, but there are a
bunch of different implementations for the estate management
APIs.
Alright. Nice.
Just because I forgot to mention to this
to you before we went live. If you
right click on the screen where the video
is and say show controls, it will allow
you to fill screen it. Because I know
that once I get my terminal and code
up, might want it slightly bigger.
It's just Oh, interesting. I don't know why
that Right click on the the the video,
like, where my browser is and say show
controls.
No?
No. You don't see it here. Oh, show
all controls. Yes. Yes. There you go. Now
you could fill screen that. I know. Which
makes There you go.
Thank you very much for that. We went
through. And then when I show you a
code, you're gonna be like, I have no
idea. So
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Was getting closer to my
screen and thinking, okay. I think that I
can read, but, yeah, I might need some
glasses.
Alright.
Do you have a preferred language as these?
I'm gonna suggest TypeScript or Go, or JavaScript
or Go. Which one would you prefer?
How how comfortable are you feeling with Go?
Yeah. I'm I'm comfortable with Go. Let's go
with Go. Let's let's let's let's do it
with JavaScript, which is something that I feel
very uncomfortable with. So let's let's do that.
Alright. Well,
we're cloning it and it isn't all that's
a JavaScript version of it. Right. Okay. Cool.
Got it. Yeah. Let's let's call it a
quick start then. So,
we start and
then we're gonna see the end to state
management JavaScript
So forth.
Mhmm. And then we're just gonna do Dapr
run.
Alright.
I trust you.
Going to the quick search first.
There we go.
I don't have any of my things. This
is gonna be so much fun. Alright.
So
this is interesting. Right? Even before I run
this command,
I ran the LS because I assumed
there was gonna be some sort of Dapr
file that told it what to do.
And there's not Let's take a look at
the let's take a look at the
instructions again.
It just says run That per yeah. Go
for it.
No.
Is it just gonna
Just to Ah, okay. Alright. Okay. Yeah. It's
there.
No. That's asking you for a file. Right?
Just do Dapr run. Let's see.
Do you have a Docker running?
I do.
Yep.
It is there.
Interesting.
Do we need do Dapr in it? Dapr
in it, maybe. Yeah. Yeah. We probably skipped
a step on getting started gate, didn't we?
Yeah. And it happened locally.
So
It's yep. Perfect. So that's gonna run, I
imagine,
some sort of a trigger. To create a
and that might create the file that you're
expecting to have there as well.
Well, no. Because well,
we'll see. Just do a less? I
don't know. I'm not so comfortable with the
with the CLI.
Alright. Well, we have something to run-in.
Yep. Yep. So
just to explain people. Right? Like, what you're
trying to do here. Right? What you're trying
to do is you're trying to so, basically,
just clone an application, and maybe we can
take a look at the application code first.
Yep.
Because
in order to understand why we are running
that Dapr
run, I think it's important to see kinda
what the application is doing anyway.
There
you go.
Alright. Perfect.
If you go to, like, the main function
there. Right? So you will see that, basically,
what it's doing is
first of all, it's creating a Dapr client.
Right? That basically means that there is an
SDK being imported in some way in JavaScript.
Right?
Because that's, like, a like, an object from
from the Dapr
library.
Yep.
So,
basically, if I guess, I'm I don't know
if you can see the import somewhere, but,
yeah, in package JSON, probably, you have that
kinda, like, dependency now. Like, you're including the
Dapr JavaScript SDK.
And
the first thing that you will do is
you are going to create a client,
and you can see that the parameters are
the host and the port, and then what
protocol do you want to use for for
that SDK, basically.
They are, like, usually, they're, like Dapr exposes
the APIs using gRPC and HTTP,
and then you can just choose which one
to use.
But then then as soon as you create
a client, basically, then you can just start
using the Dapr APIs. And in this case,
as we mentioned, we are going to be
looking into the state management APIs. That's why
in line 40,
you can see that we are doing client
state save,
basically. Right?
Where the state variable there is just a
JSON payload. It's just a JSON object. Right?
Okay.
Yeah. So
yep.
So Dapr
Mhmm. Basically,
I write my code
for my application. And
what Dapr does is give me
a client with a bunch of
integrations, one of them being a state store
here. So we have the ability to fetch
and save state.
And Mhmm. I'm assuming this works because I
saw in the dog logs here. Right? There's
a sidecar. So this is
putting my application into container, adding a safe
car,
or maybe it's not in a container right
now. I'm not even that sure. Exactly. We
have an application. We've got a Dapr sidecar
or something that the Dapr client also to
speak to which I'm assuming is just over
some sort of loopback or localhost
and it's proxying all the requests to state
storage somewhere else.
I'm pretty sure in the docs earlier on,
we saw Redis. So it's it's that what's
happening. Right?
That's what that's what happening. Right? Like, but
from your application point of view, you don't
have any Redis,
you know, dependency. Right? And you are not
even writing the code to connect to any
Redis database or anything. Right?
Yeah. So is it fair to say Dapr
is a set of abstractions on building applications
where you don't have to worry about state
or you don't have to worry about
workflows
and whatever else is on that list. Right?
PubSub.
Exactly.
Exactly. And I I think I think that
that's the idea. But, again, it's like trying
to
add this obstruction layer that will enable developers
just to code whatever they need to code
for their application.
Would they will let a different team to
worry about which components needs to be running
for these APS to have, you know, the
right backing implementations
and the right configurations and everything else that
they need for a production use case.
Now is what Dapr providing purely an abstraction,
or does it go a step further to
provide any sort of resiliency, redundancy, retry logic?
Like, what is that what is Dapr doing
when I say client save
this client state save? That's
a very that's a very good question. And,
yes, it's doing all that stuff as well.
Right? Like, we are building all best practices
and resiliency
mechanisms
on top of these calls.
Because, again, you have a proxy now between
the application
and the infrastructure. You can implement all these
functionalities because it's the perfect place to do
so.
So now you have an abstraction to access
this this in this case, this state store,
like, that can be ready, so it can
be, you know, whatever cloud provider
supported
key value store is is is supported there.
Like, even you can just swap ready for
post Postgres or any other supported implementation.
And, yeah, and and then you have all
these other super nice features that come because,
you know, you you have, like, this proxy
in the middle. You have observability.
You have resiliency.
You have security, a bunch of other things
that you will always need to implement. And
most of the time, it's delegated to the
application code to do so. And in this
case, we are doing it at this proxy
level.
Okay.
We have a good question from Marino in
the chat. He wants to understand
the cross cutting concerns of a service mesh
and Dapr. Like, do we still need a
service mesh with Dapr? Can it work with
a service mesh, or do you lose do
you just not need one with Dapr? Like,
how do you see them working together or
not?
Yeah. So there is there is definitely some
overlapping
functionalities,
but I do tend to think that Dapr
adds this application
level concerns and these APIs that usually a
service mesh will not have. Right?
So service mesh and Dapr, I think, in
my opinion, are complementary tools that you can
definitely use together, and they will be providing
different things at different levels. For example, if
you think about the observability. Right? The serve
service mesh can provide all the networking observability,
like the low level stuff, and Dapr can
add on top of that all the application
level metrics. So for example, how many keys
are you storing per second, right, and all
these things. So, again, it's like it's complementary.
Dapr can do something around, like, networking observability
as well and, example, NTLS and all that
kind of stuff. But if you have a
tool that is dedicated specifically to that, this
will complement each other for sure.
Does I mean, because
okay. Let's answer one question first. Precursor to
my next question. Right? Yes. And then I
see your question, most will get over to
that in just a second.
Say someone watches us today and they're so
impressed by Dapr. They're like, okay, I want
to start doing this. I want to make
my life a little bit easier.
Now, they've got like most organizations,
most teams, they've probably got some existing infrastructure.
Now as the approach
that well, everything should be Dapr and go
over the Dapr sidecar or can I build
one or two services with Dapr and inject
that into existing application stacks?
Yes. %. Yes. So I would I this
is my personal opinion about the Dapr project.
Right? Like, they're providing generic APIs to do
different kind of, like, very specific behaviors, in
this case, saving and retrieving, you know, key
values in this case.
That basically means that because we are we
have an obstruction here, we are not being
able to access some of the provider specific
functionalities that some teams might need. Right? In
my opinion, this obstruction aims to cover, you
know, like, 80% of the use cases that
you will implement with the key value store.
But the other 20%,
it's very specific to each vendor and maybe
kinda one feature that the vendor is providing
that it's not being shared with all the
other vendors. But, basically, we'll put you in
a position where all the generic stuff that
you can build, you can build it using
Dapr.
And all the very specific provider, you know,
like, vendor specific feature that you want to
use, you can separate it in a different
service and then consume that via APIs or
via any other interaction mechanisms.
That's kinda how I've seen Dapr being used.
Because, again, like, if, like, an architect is
looking into the like, into this, you know,
stream and saying, well, I know that by
using those generic APIs, I would not be
able to implement by very, very concrete use
case that it requires just to go straight
to the Redis APIs,
and that's perfectly fine.
But if you start using for all the
generic stuff that you're building, the Dapr APIs,
then
for all those developers, they don't actually need
to know about those vendor specific features that
you need to use. So you can just
get newer developers,
not that experienced,
in this case, with or with value store,
just coding applications and building stuff.
Okay. So let's push that a step further.
If all of my application is Dapr,
and I'm using Dapr
to communicate with the other services,
maybe
I don't need the service mesh. Does Dapr
allow me to then explore open telemetry metrics
based on traffic going through all of the
sidecars?
You can enable that. Yes. Yeah. You can
get that as well. But but this is
not the case if, like, you need a
service mesh or not.
I guess that with Dapr, for example, it
will be yeah. So for the observability point
of view, then you can ask, okay. What
what kind of metrics are you getting for
the service mesh, and what kind of metrics
is being exposed by Dapr. Right? What kind
of stuff how deep can you go, and
how well integrated it is with the rest
of the ecosystem?
I would tend to think that companies and
projects dedicated to that specific space will do
much better than a project that is much
more focused on the developer space.
Does Dapr handle service discovery between Dapr to
Dapr services, or does that rely on something
like a service mesh or Kubernetes API under
the hood?
So yeah. So so Dapr does service the
discovery, and it allows like, it implements resiliency
policies across these calls. Right? But, again, these
resiliency policies
can be
implemented by different mechanisms, and the Dapr sidecar
will have some implementations there that you can
quickly configure. Right? But it again, it's just
more focused on the application level concerns. Right?
Like, making sure that, you know, if this
service a is calling service b, you can
quickly define how many retries do you want
to do if something goes wrong, and you
can configure that in a declarative way.
Okay. That makes sense. So there is an
overlap. There is definitely an overlap there, and
I think that we're we'll be we will
be working with Marino to make sure that
that overlap, it's it's clear for people
and also that we have some very cool
examples on on how one thing can complement
the other and how people can actually benefit
from having both.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you.
Mozz asked a question. Does Dapr offer any
caching
in case
with regards to like the state management? So,
you know, if I send the same request
over and over and over again, is it
safe car gonna go? Hey, you've already sent
us and just like memoize their response.
That's a very good question. I don't like
from the top of my head. I don't
think so that that's the case, but I
can find out the more detailed answer later
on.
Alright. Hey, Carlos. Hey, Carlos. Thanks for joining.
Okay. So,
what we've seen so far,
bring in the Dapr client, we create a
client, we bring in the package,
we create a client, and then all of
a sudden we can start to call
services
obstructed
by the client. Right? So if we do
a client
dot state, maybe I don't have the packages
installed yet.
So let's do
let's just button.
Okay.
So that should if I restart my server,
give me auto complete.
No.
Alright. That goes that idea.
I just wanted to I know it does.
See. Okay. It does. Right? I I didn't
look see.
Oh, yeah. So I know that state safe.
So oh, I just don't I'm not gonna
know complete on the different
oh, no. It's at the top.
I think that's based on the strings that
are there. Right?
Yeah. So we got actor stuff, bindings,
configuration,
crypto,
focus,
proxies, pubs, sub secrets, take care. Alright. That
is quite a comprehensive set of APIs. So
I'm just gonna pick Yeah.
Two that I think are interested and then
maybe we can either take a look at
another quick start just to see what's going
on there or we can move on to
your demo. But firstly, let's try configuration.
Right? Yep.
I don't know why I keep starting at
the bottom. So I've got subscribed,
subscribed queries and get. So does this mean
Yeah.
I could just say that I want
some
mean, Configuration key. Let's call it scale scalar
number. Right? Which is just some arbitrary Exactly.
Created.
Mhmm.
A b c. This
I now have the ability to do distributed
configuration across my Dapr services.
Is that correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So you can access a
configuration kinda configuration store.
So are these gonna compare Dapr service or
pair global
application?
That's a very good question. Yeah. So as
part of the Dapr application itself, we have
scopes, and that basically give you access to
different components by name. So for example, when
you are, like, doing a a clang
state save,
you will see that the first the first
thing is the Dapr state store name. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What you can do is
you can say, you know, my state store
called
my state store
has a scope for this application
or for this list of applications. Right? Like
and then only these Dapr applications can access,
you know, that component.
Okay. So this is the store name,
and then it looks like it takes a
list. So now I could actually ask for
my scaler
number and maybe I'll see
my name, some random terrible thing. Right?
Exactly. So we get a promise, so we're
just gonna await that. And
then I get
configuration response.
Exactly.
And from there,
I can do It will be a c.
Okay. So then we get to the top.
Now there was one other interesting thing
there as we can do client configuration
and then the resubscribe.
So does this allow me to get live
updates as those values change into my application?
That's the idea. Yes. Nice.
It's a really cool feature.
And and, again, I hear that's that's kinda
interesting from lots of different perspectives. Right? Like,
you're getting functionality that usually you will need
as you are, like, figuring out. Right? Like,
when you look at that feature and you
said, okay. That's super interesting because that's something
that I will need.
And if you need to kinda, like, implement
that and figure out how this configuration store
is is doing it, then it will take
time. Here, you have kinda, like, all the
APIs with the most common, you know, functionality
already exposed there. So just autocomplete and just
figure out what what you need and then
you just you just use it. Yeah. I
mean, it's one of those things in Kubernetes.
It's just it's been a pain in the
ass from day one. Right? It's where the
content map changes, and you have to find
a way to rotate that Mhmm. Point.
We've done Exactly. Past via terrible annotations with
hashes.
We're making content maps immutable and force and
deployment that way. But really, our conflict could
just be delivered at run time through some
system like And I love that the API
is just right there for you to use
even with the subscribe, which is such a
nice touch.
Exactly.
Because think about this. Now you have this
proxy that usually, like, when you start using
Dapr, you would think that it's just a,
like, unidirectional.
Right? Like, you're going to infrastructure and sending
request to infrastructure.
But because this proxy is, like, it's long
running and it's running right beside your application,
can also call back the application whenever it's
needed. So for that subscribe mechanism, basically, you
would just get the notification
back into the application when something changes.
The same with pops up. Right? Like, with
pops up, you are interested in receiving events
whenever they happen in Kafka or in or
whatever, and you want to make sure that
the application gets called back whenever a new
event happens.
I
think you've you've led yourself in to a
very tough question there because you put an
idea in my head and that's never a
good thing.
Oh, no.
I am a huge fan of
Kafka esque APIs,
that style of topic based pub sub, right,
especially red panda, that's an amazing project. Right?
But there's a challenge. Right? And the challenge
is that we usually need some sort of
two phase thing. We save something to a
database, we grab our pub sub, we publish
the thing. Yep.
This is a transaction even though we don't
treat it as a transaction. Now I'm hoping
you're tell me I can do start
transaction and then wrap these two things. Is
that something that Dapr is gonna solve for
me, or would I still need to handle
that on a case It's it's it's
much better than that, my friend. I'm I'm
glad I'm glad that you asked that.
So there is a way to configure
the the state store to actually implement the
outbox pattern, which is what you're describing. You
want in the same transaction to to to
store a state and then immediate message with
that state, with the payload. Right?
So there is a way to automatically enable
that for the state store for the save.
Right? So when you do save, you know
that depending on the configuration of that, an
an an event can be immediately in the
same transaction as well.
And that's not there. It's not it's not
in the APIs. It's more like a configuration
space, and you can you can take a
look in into the website.
Okay. So let's go back to the docs
then because that's that's really interesting. Right? Because
this is just something that's Yeah. Always been
super hard. Right?
Exactly.
And again, this is kinda going back to
what I mentioned before. Right? Like, we are
building more complex functionality based on the building
blocks. Right? Like, we we can store state
and we can meet events.
Now we can bundle them in the same
transaction
if we want to.
Alright. So
where should I be looking?
I think that now, like, basically, it will
ask you to
run the, like, Dapr run. Right?
What what are you looking for?
That configuration thing you were talking about.
Oh, so we need to take a look
for the, like, out outbox pattern. So if
you search in the documentations,
outbox
There you go.
And I think that that's the configuration out
there. Right? Like, that's
basically the the YAML file that you're looking
into is how do you configure the backing
implementations.
Right? Ah, right. So in this case
in this case, you are using a state
store that is MySQL.
Right? So in this case, you are storing
this key value objects into MySQL.
You have, like, the connection string, of course,
to the instance of the database.
And then down there, like, the the the
next, metadata that you have there is out
outbox publish pops up.
Right? Like, that basically means every time that
you do a save
state, you're going to be creating a message
into
that pops up on the topic that basically
you are defining there. Yep.
That's nice.
I was not expecting you to tell me
it was that easy, but I'm very I'm
very happy that it is that easy.
And and I think that this is what
makes the project really, really,
really powerful in in a sense that
if you start building more and more complex
patterns like this one. Right? Because these are
the difficult challenges that developers needs to solve.
And if you summarize all these things into
some APIs and some configurations,
then, actually, you can have, like,
you know, less experienced developers
building very complex functionality.
Sweet.
Alright. Let let's get back on track. So
Yeah. That
was cool. I'm just worried this. I bet
you should it's only me that really cares,
but I really love that that bit of
functionality.
So we're taking a look at state management.
I'm just gonna see if there's anything that
didn't take a look at that it's gonna
cover.
So run it, see it save stuff
and now okay. So now we're getting the
ability to add a YAML file for multi
app.
That's that's I don't think that you need
that right now. Let me see.
Yep. Yeah. You do need that, I think.
Okay. Yeah. That's you need that because that's
the file.
Yeah. That's the file that you need to
use to basically run the the order processor,
which is the application that you clone.
Alright.
So I probably don't want us to save
any of those changes. And the filename that
we need is Dapr dot YAML.
Always YAML.
Always YAML. And
I'm gonna use button. There we go.
And then you have the other file, which
is the the one that we were looking
at before. Right? Like, this is the state
store definition,
using Redis.
This YAML file, this one specifically,
is the one that, basically a platform engineering
team needs to define and configure, right, based
on the the, like, available infrastructure that they
have.
Okay.
So state store, we have. And now
You did that already. Right? Yeah. You did
that. Yeah.
What is that? Yeah. Now you need to
run the app, I guess. You should be
able to run the app and
oh, there you go. Yep. Mhmm. Just
to recap. Right? Like, you are not running
Kubernetes.
In this case, you are starting Dapr outside
of Kubernetes.
And the Dapr CLI, it's basically configuring Dapr
to have, like, an instance of Redis, I
think, locally running with Docker
and connecting to that one.
You need to do I think that you
need to do the other command. Yeah.
Not that. I think that you need the
the long one. That one. And Dapr Dapr
run.
But haven't I just Yeah. Described all this
stuff?
Oh, no. That's order processor. Okay. Alright. Okay.
Gotcha.
Exactly. We have state management, so that's a
separate application together.
Alright.
What can we see there? Did you change
something
in the app?
No. That's the order processor. I have not
touched the order processor.
Yeah. I think it wants me to be
in a different direction. Yeah. Okay. This is
it actually wants me to go into that
application.
That's Into the other processor. Yeah. Okay. So
I've I've been scrolling too fast. Right? So
we set up the environment. That's right. Which
Dapr run. We've seen this one run. I
think we're happy that that one just worked.
Right? So let's do it again. And
my Dapr logs will appear here.
Easy. So
it looks like we ever got logs from
it.
No. Because that's, like, that's not running the
application. That's only starting the Dapr APIs. Right?
Like, on your application is not running. That's
why the other Dapr run is basically running
the Dapr sidecar that you're running there plus
the application at the end. You can see
that there is an NPM start at the
end.
Not not in that command. Okay.
Okay.
So I can now do bun run
that Mhmm.
That's your that's
your path again.
Yeah.
I hate myself so much right now.
Humber a bit. You
know, I I really I really don't care
because I know that you know how to
fix it. If I need to fix this
live, I would be struggling.
Oh, okay. So there's a start, the start
Dapr. We've already done the start Dapr, so
I'm just going to start.
Yep. Waiting for a sidecar, which should still
be running.
Yeah. But are you trying to
start it? It's like a start
the start up. Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. Just the
start.
I'm waiting for a sidecar. Okay.
That might be because
so if you do, like for example, if
you do
okay. So That was, a run. Update email
not supported.
Uh-huh.
Interesting. Is this just because I'm being an
absolute pain in the ass and using BUN?
Am I just I don't think so.
Am I breaking your demo?
Maybe.
But that's what what demos are for. Right?
I know. It does the same with NPM.
It says that HTTP is not supported, deprecation
warning.
And
yeah. So maybe you just found a bug
or something because I guess that that the
Java SDK is trying to use HTTP for
some reason. So if you look at the
source code in into the application,
remember that there is kinda, like, a protocol
being defined on top. Right? Yeah. The thing
was here. So shall we switch it to
gRPC?
Just switch it to gRPC. Yeah.
I'm just It's checking for, like, an environment
vial. Right? Yeah. Yeah. I'm just gonna cheat.
So
To gRPC
straight away.
Mhmm.
Same.
Configuration store is not configured.
Yeah. That's because, like, if you take a
look at the command in the documentation, you
need to use that,
like, the Dapr
Dapr JAML file that you're not pointing to
to start Dapr.
Alright.
Are you are you running Dapr in a
different way or not? Like Well, no. It's
have it in a different terminal? There's a
bug in your docs because it says, not
your docs, you know what mean, but it
says run Yeah. Run dash f, but that
that's not enough. It seems to be That's
not enough. And I think that the documentation
is building. We are not reading all the
lines, so I guess that the real command
that we need to run, it's down the
end. So if you check out the at
the last command
in the docs, I think that the code
documentation is building just to make sure that
you run different things.
That one. Because that one is, like, pointing
to the resource paths resources.
I know, but we try to find that
in a Dapr dot YAML. So I feel
like we shouldn't have to do that again.
Yeah. Yeah. That's
true. Let me see. Okay. Let's take a
look at the Dapr dot YAML file.
I would just want to make sure that
we are pointing to the right state store
YAML file. Right? Like, that's what we we
should check.
Alright. So does Yeah. So Is
that yeah. Exactly. We need to check that
that is pointing to the right place. Right?
It doesn't look like there there is any
resources there. Right? Three. Oh, there you go.
Oh, okay. So that's the the one there.
And this is actually our
date.
Though that's the app ID, so the concept
of application ID, it's basically giving, like, the
application an identity. Right? Like, in this case,
we have an application that's called order processor.
And this is kinda going back to the
thing that you asked before,
the idea of having scopes.
Okay.
Hey.
Oh, no. Then you oh, what's but what
do you see? What is that?
Configuration stores is
ah, it says configuration
store. Is that can you save your source
code?
Are you still using the configuration APIs?
Yes.
There you go.
Yep.
David strikes. There you go.
There you go. Well, it that was not
an easy thing to to see about. Yeah.
We need to read the error messages. There
you go. You just shouldn't trust me to
do demos. That's what it is.
No. No. I love it. I love it.
Good question for Mars.
Do we not need Redis? Where's where's Redis?
Like, what's happening? Yes.
Yeah. What's so what's happening? It's like, remember
that you run kinda like Dapr in it?
Mhmm. So if you do so if you
stop that oh,
stop that and do docker ps. Yeah.
You see that there is a Redis there.
Right? And, basically,
what the Dapr CLI is doing is just
when you do Dapr init, basically, it will
create a bunch of things out of the
box.
An interesting thing about Redis is that Redis
provides you kinda like an implementation for the
state management APIs, but also for PubSub.
So you can actually use, you know, Redis
to kinda move events around different applications. And
that's the main reason why, like, we wanted
to do kinda like a very quick easy
experience for people to not even worry about
Redis and start using, you know, the APIs
straight away.
How much of this is swappable? See, I
don't want to use Riders. I wanna use
CouchDB or MongoDB,
Postgres.
Like, is that something Dapr supports, or is
it very opinionated on what the back end
services are provided by?
No. No. No. Like, quite the opposite. I
we're just trying to support as many as
we can. So if you go to the
to the docs, I think that if you
go to the website,
you will see that
there there should be kind of the reference,
like, section, I think.
Mhmm.
And then if you look for,
component
reference,
state stores,
there you go. You have, like, the link
Wow. Yeah, of what it's supported.
So you have stuff that is self hosted
and also, like, cloud provider specific stuff. Right?
I mean, I'm I'm a postgres person. I'll
be just Yeah. I would just I would
use postgres for everything.
There you go. I then it makes total
sense. But if you scroll down, you will
see that you can swap Postgres for any
cloud provider
supported, you know, thing. Yeah. And and and
so
that's pretty cool too. Mhmm.
Yep.
Sweet. Well, that's that's the idea. And remember,
right, like, the whole point of of this
thing that we are trying to show here
is that developers can use these tools to
build the functionality.
Right? And they can trust that the APIs
will behave the same in kinda, in a
more serious environment that may be running Kubernetes
or maybe running in a cloud provider. Because
the APIs will remain the same, but the
configuration on how the components are wired and
how the, you know, infrastructure is configured, it's
it's, you know, the the
it's the responsibility of a different team.
This is cool.
Good flexibility on the secret stores too.
Mhmm. I'm just gonna look at everything. I'm
just so curious.
Yeah. So for example
yeah. Because, like, that's another thing that people
will need, like, distributed locks. Right? Just need,
a way to say, okay. I want to
have a distributed lock implementation. You can do
that with that.
Nice. Very cool. Alright.
I I could explore this for hours,
but I'm gonna try not to do But
we want it we want it working. Right?
I feel that's kinda important. Like, at least
they're getting a start up experience.
Yeah. We did. So, you know, I always
like to do little recaps,
but,
know, the Dapr promise here is,
heck your language
of which there was a few supported. Right?
So you've got the buried
Python,
JavaScript, I'll assume TypeScript is just supported
by default.
Any of the dot net languages, I'm assuming
Java and go. Like, what is the
other plans to add more languages, like like
Rust,
for instance? Yeah. Yeah. So there is a
Rust SDK as well.
But, yeah, it's kinda community support. It really
depends on on how much community do we
do we get, and if we can get,
like, someone to help us to create the
SDK. There were some conversations about creating some
Swift also, like Apple with SDKs,
which makes a lot of sense because when
you think about these APIs, I do think
a lot about, like, mobile as well. Right?
Like, you can build an application and just
use these APIs to, basically,
do the back end implementations of things.
So, yeah,
they are, like, more I think that if
you go to the GitHub repository, you will
find, like, all the SDKs as well.
Let me see if I can quickly check.
Yeah. DaprDapr..com
Dapr Dapr. And then I think that you
need to search for so sorry. No. It's
like just Dapr,
the org. If you go to the org
and then search for repositories
with SDK in Rust, c plus plus, PHP.
Mhmm. So
why are those those just aren't on the
documentation page because their community is supported at
the moment. Is that right?
Yeah. And probably, they are a little bit
less mature. Right? So or probably, we don't
have someone, you know, like the Rask one
is marked as alpha because, again, we probably
have a single community member contributing.
And most of the other SDKs, are, like,
different companies helping and and providing implementations and
tests and making sure that the the SDKs
work.
So I'm guessing that the ones that are
listed there are part of, like, the, like,
the main project release process,
and that's why they are just listed and
documented all over the place.
Alright. So,
again, back to the recap. We have lots
of supported languages,
potential for more, if you're well dependent effort
to work on an SDK.
Once you have the client and your application,
you start to consume the APIs. We've seen
state management or pubsub,
binders and actors. Let's go back to that
in a moment and have a quick conversation.
Secrets management config, cool, workflow and cryptography.
So
what are bindings?
Bindings. Think about bindings. I would like interacting
with external
services.
Right? Like, external APIs.
Imagine that you want to call, like,
Stripe APIs. What is that example doing? Interacting
with the cron job or something. Right?
Let's take a look at the Go code
this time.
Don't know what Yeah. Think that's just just
basically executing some external stuff. Right? Okay.
Yeah.
But this is a cron to run every
ten seconds.
Exactly. But by things, I think that it's
like it's like a an API just that
enable you to create different connections to different
things that are not covered by the other
APIs.
Right? Imagine that you want to interact with
a payment service or something, and you want
to use the same, you know, resiliency policies
that you're using for all the other APIs.
Or, like, this gives you all those mechanisms,
but an extension point just to interact with
whatever you want.
Alright.
Actors.
I'm a big fan of the actor model,
so I'm hoping that Dapr is gonna make
my life a lot easier there too.
Yeah. So this have, like, a lot of
that stuff in there. I'm not the big
fan of that either, and I'm not an
expert on myself.
But, yeah, that provides you kinda get an
actor runtime inside the sidecar itself. Yeah. .Net
is really leading the charge with actor stuff,
especially the Orleans project where you have got
virtual actors. The idea being that every entity
within your system, like, user would be a
virtual actor. You could send messages to that
one specific actor and then react to it.
It's such a cool part.
I haven't seen
anything real worldly production
except for our stuff on top of New
Orleans.
The stuff on top of Orleans and I'd
love to see other languages really get there.
Alright. And then lastly, we've got workflows,
which you kind of spoke about briefly, but
this is durable execution.
Exactly. Super exciting things. Right? Because we all
want more resilient and reliable applications. So this,
I love that Dapr is gonna make that
easier too.
Yeah. And and you can imagine, right, like,
workflows needs to store a state. Workflows will
emit events when they move from from different
activities, and you want to make sure that,
you know, if you're trying to execute something
or waiting on something for five minutes and
it's not happening, then you can immediately vent.
All those kind of patterns can be built
with this functionality.
Alright. Awesome.
One thing that I wanted to one thing
that I wanted to clarify on the languages,
right, because I think that this is important.
As I mentioned at the beginning, right, like,
Dapr is exposing HTTP and gRPC endpoints.
So if for some reason, you are working
with a language that it's not currently supported
and we don't provide an SDK, you can
actually craft the HTTP request or the gRPC
requests
by hand, and you don't actually need to
add any library to your application.
Oh, so I could just generate a gRPC
client from the profile, so then use it
in any language, really. %.
Yeah.
Oh, you're making me smile. I like it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is this is
pretty good. The the the main thing about,
like, the SDKs is that we will try
to make things even easier for developers to
get started with basic stuff.
Right?
But, yeah, like, even you can just do
actually HTTP. Right? Like, if you're in a
limit limited device where gRPC is not available
or whatever, you can just go HTTP. The
HTTP way will just send a post request
to an URL in local host, and there
you go.
Alright.
Do you still wish to show us something
interesting?
I can try to show something in in
less than ten minutes, like, pretty much the
same thing that you showed, but something that
I've been working on that maybe it's maybe
worth to discuss a little bit. Yeah. Let's
go for it. If you just wanna pull
it up, and I'll stick your screen on
in just a second.
Let's do it.
Alright. And you see my screen? Yep. We
see your terminal.
Perfect.
Let me see if I can find another
thing that I wanted to show here.
So sorry about that. So yeah. So, like,
a little bit of background
on this. Basically, I I'm just writing a
series of blog posts, and I've started with
State Store. The same reason why we started
here because it's kinda, like, easy to get
what it's doing.
But the main thing that I'm trying to
cover in this block series,
and I'm doing kinda, like, examples with that,
is how do you like, the developer experience.
Right? You just use the Dapr c like,
the Dapr CLI. And for that, you can
actually need to learn how Dapr,
the APIs,
and what does it means, and how Dapr
works because you're starting some containers locally.
And that might be a little bit too
complicated for developers that are not even interested
in that. They just want to use if
we want to enable developers to use the
APIs,
we just need to integrate a little bit
deeper with their ecosystem.
And I've been working kinda with some Dapr
and Spring Boot integrations
that basically it's they are aiming for just
doing that. So the blog post basically covers
kinda like the APIs.
And let me show you here. So I
have, like
this is like a Java application using the
state store APIs. Same way, same thing, basically,
that what you saw. Like, we are using,
you know, client. We have a Dapr client.
And as soon as we have a Dapr
client, we have, like, the same state API
here. Right? Same thing. We need the state
state store name, and then we will just
send the customer object in this case that
will be serialized
and stored in a key value store somewhere.
And, again, two different functions, two different methods
here in Java, and another one for just
reading state, just getting, in this case, a
customer information
into the key value store. Same thing.
The only big difference here is that I
don't have the Dapr CLI installed, and I
do not have anything Dapr
related running.
But with this kinda, like, integration between Spring
Boot and Dapr, which is basically a dependency
that we need to add to our application
that I'm trying to figure out where it
is here. So there is just a dependency
that you add that basically will bring some
configurations using a project that's called test containers
to bootstrap
all the Dapr related configuration for this Spring
Boot application.
And what lets me what this lets me
do is that I cannot only
start my application and Dapr at the same
time, but what I can do now is
I can write some tests testing for my
application
that basically will use that configuration.
The when when I'm starting my tests, Dapr
will be started, configured,
and be ready for my application to basically
call the APIs.
So I have a simple application level a
test here, which is basically calling my application
APIs.
But in the background, the test container library
and the Dapr integration will bootstrap all the
things that Dapr needs
for for this specific application without the developer
basically understanding what Dapr is or how is
it configured. They only need to the only
thing that they need is just what you
were doing before, David, which is, like, just
have the ID, just to auto complete all
the operations that we have for different,
you know, building blocks that we expose.
And just to show that, basically,
we use Maven in in in Java. I
don't know how many people is familiar with
that, but what I wanted to show here
is that I can do something like test
run-in this case, which basically will allow me
to start the application in in kind of
some kind of, like, development mode.
And when I run this,
if I'm in the right place I'm not
in the right place there. There you go.
That's the customer catalog service that I built.
When I run this, basically, what I would
have is my application starting.
But as you can see here in the
logs, you will see if I make it
a little bit smaller,
you will see that when my application start,
it also brings, you know, some Dapr containers
into the mix. That basically means that now
my application can call these APIs, and I
can send request to these, you know, to
these APIs
and and and just use them.
There you go. Wrong wrong directory. So in
this case, I'm just sending a customer to
my, you know, to my h HTTP endpoint
that is being exposed by the application.
And this piece this is using the state
store API to store it in Redis or
in in somewhere. Like, from the developer point
of view, it doesn't really matter where it's
getting stored. The only thing that it matters
is that it's actually doing that. I can
actually test that by just sending another request
just to get that customer by ID, and
and there you go. So there you have
it.
For we David, we haven't talked about Kubernetes
at all. So if we have, kinda like,
two minutes, I can show something around that
space just for people to understand how it
works usually.
Yeah. Of course. I'll I'll also say that
in over 200
Rawkode lives, you're the first person to ever
show Java code.
There you go.
That's kinda interesting. And I think that that's
a there is a reason behind that.
I I'm a strong believer that
at the beginning, kinda like Java took quite
a lot of time to get into the
Kubernetes land, but now more and more companies
that are Java based, are Java shops,
are reaching to this maturity level where they
actually want their to get their Java workloads
up and running. The
the main reason why I'm building this integration
is because we want to make sure that
for these teams,
we just made their life easier. We're just
not adding crazy new tools and new workflows.
They just gonna keep doing what they're doing,
building applications in the same way, and and
just running these applications in Kubernetes.
So what I did before is just run
the application locally. What I will do now,
if you don't mind, I will just use
kind to create a cluster. K. Create cluster.
Right? So that's for people who doesn't know,
I guess, that they you know, like, just
the local Kubernetes cluster. Right? Yep.
Pretty simple stuff.
When you use the Dapr CLI, again, we
were using Docker to start
what we call the Dapr sidecar.
That's the sidecar that will be running very
close to your application with all the APIs.
Right?
And when you're running in Kubernetes, it's a
little bit different. What we do is we
install a control plane, a Dapr control plane
into your cluster.
And that control plane will be looking for
all the workloads that are running in the
cluster that contain some annotations
and only enable those workloads with the Dapr
APIs.
So let's just do that, I guess. Let
me install let's install Dapr.
You install the Dapr control pane using Helm.
There are a couple of different alternatives. I
think that we have an operator
that was created for OpenShift that you can
use as well,
or you can use the operator for any
other kind of clusters as well.
So this is basically installing, you know, a
health chart that contains all the Dapr
control plane components that are looking for Dapr
workflows and Dapr workloads and also connecting the
component definitions that we have.
So
what we just did is that
just created a new namespace,
and a couple of components are running inside
these reports.
Alright. So that's the control plane. Right? Like,
there are a bunch of things running
in there. And one of those things, the
one that I wanted to show is this,
like, this this thing that is called Dapr
sidecar injector.
This is basically that controller
that it's looking for workloads with certain notations.
When an annotation is detected, that basically means
that we need to go and inject the
sidecar to that application.
So to run the same service that I
was running locally into a Kubernetes cluster, of
course, I need to create a container for
that Java application.
I already did that.
And then the other thing that I wanted
to do here is one more thing that
it's kinda important. It's installed Redis right, in
my cluster because I want to use Redis
now
for the
for the key value store.
So I would just run this helm command
to create a new Redis instance.
Pretty standard stuff.
As we discussed before, David, this can be
PostgreSQL.
It can be any of those, you know,
implementations that were shared there. Whatever you want,
you just install one, and then you just
need to configure Dapr to understand that this
is the thing that you want to use
for your for one of your estate store
implementations.
And you do that by
doing something similar that we did before. Let
me just refresh that. This case, I'm saying,
you know, I have a new state store
called t k k v store, and it's
using Redis as an implementation.
That's the URL of the service that it's
running inside Kubernetes. And when you install the
Helm chart of Redis, it creates a secret
that contains the password to connect to that
specific instance.
Right? So we'll just apply this
state store,
and now I have my key value store
Dapr component created.
That basically means that whenever I want to
use the state stores APIs
and I'm referencing this specific state store, I
will be using Redis for storing my key
values.
So I have everything now in my cluster
for running my application, and I have Redis
running. It's up and running, so that's pretty
cool. And the last thing that I need
to do, and I think that I can
show this in Versus code, is that, basically,
I need to deploy my application. Right? So
I've created a container with the same application
that I was running before.
I'm configuring, you know, an environment variable with
the name of the key value store that
I want to use.
And then I have a service
for the for the deployment so I can
send request
to this to this application later on. So
let's just do that.
Does that make sense, David? So far? Yeah.
Yeah. Something that you want to ask or
perfect.
No. Let's deploy that. Sense. Yeah.
Cool. Cool. And, of course, this probably will
need to fetch the container from Docker Hub
at some point to the cluster that I
just created.
And you will see that, yep, there you
go. So we have, like, the customer service
being deployed.
And as you can see here, Dapr, the
Dapr control plane detected that my my application
requires Dapr, and that's because I have these
annotations here in my deployment,
which basically are saying that, yeah, I want
to enable the Dapr for this application.
And then my application identity is customer service
in this case. Right? So if somebody wants
to call, like, the customer service application,
needs to go with using that name basically
later on. Remember that we saw some, like,
service discovery and service to service invocation functionality?
Well, that's the ID of this service now.
This is how you kinda, like, define that.
I guess that it would check now. K.
They're like we're having restarts there. That basically
means that I messed up with something somewhere,
which is kinda funny because I just tested
this, and it was working.
This this should go out tomorrow for a
blog post, but let's let's do this.
And if it doesn't work, that's fine, but
I just wanted to show it working.
Let's see.
So the application is running correctly, so I'm
guessing that I configured something wrong with Dapr.
Oh, no. Let me see.
Oh, it's running now. Yeah. So, basically, something
not being connected and for some reason restarting.
Let's see.
Yep. Now it's running. Okay. Perfect. Pretty cool.
The last thing that I want to do
so now remember, now we're we were running
the application before locally as a developer. Now
we basically deploy the same application into
a Kubernetes cluster that has the Dapr control
pane installed, and it has Redis. And it
also has this resource that it's called component
here
that we call we call it k kv
store in this case. Right? That's all all
we need. And then, basically, when we configure
the application to use the state store APIs,
we just use that string
to make reference to that specific key value
store. That basically means that you can have
tons of different key value stores and then
just make reference to each of them using
kinda just the screen.
And
to test this, basically, we can do
use CTL
or forward, right, just to access the service.
That's my service up and running there, and
I can send exactly the same requests that
I sent before,
to the service that's now running on Kubernetes.
Right? So now this is just running on
my cluster.
It might take a while. There you go
for the first request.
But as soon as I send these and
I get the 200, that basically means that,
of course, that my service worked, but also
that the service that it's using the state
store APIs is working, and this data is
stored in Redis.
And I can just call the other request,
cancel another request to get the
HTTP,
to get the customer by ID. There you
go.
So we have configured
the same application that we were running locally
into a Kubernetes cluster
with maybe different back in back in services
in this case. Like, for the local environment,
we didn't even knew if we had Redis
or something in memory or maybe even using
kind of Postgres or something different. But for
the environment that it's running in Kubernetes, we
are using Redis,
and the APIs are working kinda, like, in
the same way.
Hopefully, that makes some sense. I know that
I rushed it a bit, but, hopefully, it
kinda, like,
builds up on the things that we were
talking before.
No. Definitely made sense. Answered a few questions
I had. You know, I I like that
we can deploy multiple versions of the
let me get this back onto big face
mode. I like the way can deploy a
postcards in the Redis and have multiple keys
value stores,
and our applications can packages the ones that
make sense for the data type of restoring
and then Dapr just layers on all of
this extra simplicity to build and distribute applications,
which, you know, again, I said at the
start, it's something that we need. These these
things are hard to build and
more opinionated ways to do things. So little
Dapr's
opinionated API, but so flexible in the back
end. I feel weird even just saying as
opinion, know, it's it's it's nice. I think
we need more stuff like this. So Yeah.
Yeah. My my my hope for this is
that the APIs becomes more robust over time.
Right? Like, we add more and more and
more functionality that it's being used by by
people, more and more people in production, and
for building more complex software. Right? We have
a lot of people using the Dapr project,
but we want to hear more about kinda
what people wants to do with this. And,
you know, if you have any questions or
any follow ups, feel free to reach out.
Alright. Awesome. Well, I'm gonna give everyone that's
watching the two minute warning. If you do
have a question and you wanna answer, drop
it into the comments now,
and I'll throw a question at you while
we we we wait for a minute or
two.
So
you're now working for the company behind Dapr
and Dagrat. Right?
That's correct. Yes.
You wanna what can you give us on,
like, a roadmap? Like, what are what are
you focuses on on a company? What's coming
next for Dapr? Is it just languages? Is
it maturity? Is it new APIs? Like, what
does the next twelve months look like if
you're if you have that information?
You know that twelve months, it's it's pretty
a long, long, long period of time in
this industry. So tons of different things can
happen. First of all, I'm working, for this,
company that's called Diagrid, and it's not the
only company behind the project. Right? Like, we
have a lot of different companies participating. We
have a very, very large community of companies
building on top of this, including Microsoft and
a bunch of other companies.
So there are tons of things been happening
in the community.
In my specific area, I'm really looking forward
to build some integrations cross cross communities using
different projects. Because I'm interested in in, you
know, in, like, in the developer productivity space
and developer tools.
I think that I will be doing something
around open feature, which is feature guidance.
I
would I would love to have, like, the
API just to consume feature flags straight away
from from the Dapr, you know, SDKs. That's
something that I've been looking for a long
time. And also because I was working and
I'm still working on the k native project,
I want to make sure that you can
build very, very robust
functions
and try to build that kind of, like,
Lambda experience where you can connect to infrastructure
pretty easily from different functions.
And, for that, I'm just basically collaborating with,
the project and also, they say, Chinese led
project called Open Function as well. Yeah. That
it's using Dapr and,
you know, and and just merging a bunch
of technologies
that I believe that that's kinda it's pretty
cool to see that they are, like, just
gluing up a bunch of projects together, that
it's not easy.
But what I see I see there, it's
a lot of opportunity to build more complex
use cases and to highlight the functionality of
all of these projects working together.
So, yeah, that's kinda like what's coming from
the open source side of things. From, the
company point of view, we announced at KubeCon,
a new product, basically, which is some kind
of, like, a Dapr
as service kind of thing. Right? Like so
you have the APIs in a managed service
that you can just interact from your applications
without running Kubernetes
or Dapr itself to just interact with some
APIs that you create an account. You have
the APIs just to start building applications.
And I think that's a pretty powerful thing.
And I will Sorry.
I don't mean to cut you off. Please
finish.
No. No. No. Go go ahead. I think
that that's pretty much it. Well, I I
really like all of these,
you know,
very easy to consume
functions as a service serverless platform. Not so
much Lambda, more specifically,
what Fairmain are doing with Fairmain cloud and
web assembly, what Cloudflare are doing with workers,
you know, Firebase functions. And
I guess with a managed service Dapr and
it's providing state storage and stuff like that.
Like my serverless functions can be fully fledged
applications and speak to these APIs and they
could be, you know, have much more features
in them that would necessarily be difficult or
would have been or I can't speak. Would
have been harder or more difficult to do
without such a service.
Is that something you see you see growing,
I guess?
Yeah. Yeah. %. Right? Like, the idea here
is that no matter where your applications are
running, they can always access these APIs just
to implement things against any infrastructure.
So we we give you two things in
the same way that Dapr is giving you.
Right? Like, we give you the APIs, but
also the possibility to configure the back end
infrastructure if you want to. If not, we
will give you some implementations that are there
going to be very opinionated to the service
itself.
Right? We will say, you know, we know
how to manage
this implementation like this technology,
so we will give you these APIs with
this backing implementation and just focus on the
using the APIs.
Nice. And that opt that open ups the
doors to, you know, like, if you're running
on Google Cloud Run or or or Lambdas
or whatever just to know that, you know,
no matter what you're running, you just can
connect to those APIs.
And the nice thing is that we are
fully compatible with the Dapr project. That basically
means that when you create a Dapr client
as we did,
you just put, like, an API token there.
And and just like the URL, now it's
not going to be localhost. It's going to
be the remote service.
There you go.
Nice.
Very, very cool. Well, we have no further
questions from the chat. So with that, I'll
just say thank you. I think we definitely
need to schedule another session in the New
Year where we try and generate a GRPC
client and rust and do something really cool.
But I'll catch up with you about that
after the holidays.
And any final words or anything you want
to share before we say goodbye?
I think that, for me, it's really important
to tell people that if they are open
to contribute, you see that, like, this project
is very polyglot. So no matter what kind
of experience do you have, if you want
to contribute with the SDKs or the project
itself,
feel free to reach out. If you are
interested in in testing these new APIs that
that we are building at Diagrid, also, need
a lot of people and a lot of
eyes looking into these APIs and to the
service itself. If you go to diagrid.io,
you can just actually get kinda like like,
trial account and just give it a try
as well. And if you have any feedback,
please feel free to reach out. I'm always
open and happy to help people.
Awesome. Thank you so much. Alright. With that,
I'll say you have a wonderful day. I'll
hopefully speak to you soon. Thanks to everyone
watching. We'll see you later.